[Musique]
journée un petit peu spéciale on va
procéder au nettoyage de la rivière
Mauldre qui passe derrière la mairie de
Beynes donc c'est un nettoyage annuel
effectué par l'association de pêche et
donc cette année on a décidé enfin j'ai
décidé de me joindre à l'association de
pêche pour leur apporter de l'aide et
puis des connaissances il y a aussi
quelques collègues echoga qui vont se
joindre à nous pour nous prêter
main-forte et pour pouvoir travailler
plus efficacement
[Musique]
on va nettoyer la rivière sur un petit
peu plus de 2 km c'est la distance du
parcours de pêche mais il faut savoir
que la rivière est beaucoup plus longue
que de kilomètres donc on va pas pouvoir
tout nettoyer aujourd'hui une dame les
tubes des déchets qu'on va retrouver
dans La Môle ça va être principalement
des déchets végétaux des branchages du
bois mais aussi de la boue qui va
obstruer l'écoulement de la rivière et
on retrouve aussi beaucoup de déchets de
qui proviennent de l'homme des canettes
des sachets en plastique et puis des
gravats etc donc c'est c'est dangereux
pour la faune la flore et puis ça pollue
l'environnement donc on va essayer de
faire la sensibilisation pour limiter ce
phénomène
[Musique]
donc voilà vous avez vu aujourd'hui la
journée un petit peu type d'un éco garde
il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres missions
comme la sensibilisation des riverains
le ramassage des déchets l'évacuation
des dépôts avec les services techniques
de la mairie bien évidemment qui me
prêtent ma force et puis tout ce qui est
aussi réunion et puis projet
administratifs organisation de la Fête
de la Nature c'est vraiment tout ce qui
a trait à l'environnement moi j'aime
bien résumer le poste comme
principalement de la patrouille sur le
chemin communaux mais aussi de la
coordination de tous les acteurs
environnementaux de la commune si vous
aussi vous voulez devenir ecoga c'est
possible en tant que professionnel
aujourd'hui je suis le seul sur le
département des Yvelines mais vous
pouvez toujours devenir bénévole grâce
aux dispositifs ecoguard donc merci et à
bientôt
[Musique]